president trump is not conceding nor
should he
however yesterday on twitter
hashtag trump conceded was trending
that's very strange why would trump
conceded trend if trump did not concede
president trump has tweeted that just
just this morning he tweeted out
something to the effect of i will win we
won the election
a couple days ago he tweets out rigged
election we will win all caps
another tweet i concede nothing but then
there was a third tweet
and people are misunderstanding this
because they don't know how to speak
trump broadly they don't know how to
speak new yorker but they
specifically don't have to speak trump
he tweeted out quote
he won because the election was rigged
no vote watchers or observers allowed
vote tabulated by radical left privately
owned company dominion
with a bad reputation and bum equipment
they couldn't even qualify for texas
which i won by a lot
the fake and silent media and more
so they're saying because he said
because trump said he won
referring to biden then he is conceding
the election
now you can say trump doesn't use
proper diction he his grammar is
eccentric you can say all those things
but no one can honestly read
what trump said as him conceding
and my evidence for this is he used the
same
sort of linguistic structure when he was
talking about john mccain you remember
trump got in a lot of trouble because he
said john mccain's not a war hero
are we famous they said johnny is not a
war hero biden continues to attack him
for saying john mccain's not a war hero
the way he said it though was exactly
the way that he said joe biden
didn't win the election joe biden did
win the election take a listen to the
infamous mccain comment
he hit me he's not a war hero he's a
warrior five and a half years he's a war
hero because he was captured
i like people that weren't captured okay
i hate to tell you do you
hear that notorious comment how dare
trump say that okay you can
you can dislike the comment all you like
and you can dislike what he's saying
about joe biden right now
but you have to admit when joe when when
trump says
he won because the election was rigged
what he is saying is
people believe that joe biden won
because the election is rigged
even though he didn't really win just as
he said
john mccain's not a war hero he's a war
hero because he was shot down
he's not he's not contradicting himself
he's not saying john mccain's not a war
hero oh actually he is a war hero he's
saying john mccain's not a war hero
people believe he is a war hero because
he's shot down but nevertheless my
assertion is true he's not a he is not a
war hero
same thing here joe biden did not win
the election
people think he won because you know all
this voter fraud or whatever uh but he
did he didn't really win that's what
he's saying you can disagree with that
all you want
and we'll find out there's gonna be a
legal process that plays out to see who
ends up being
ultimately named president we may never
know who got the most votes
people might have a hunch who got the
most votes but we may never know for
sure
stuffing the ballot box is notoriously
difficult to figure out
it took the the lbj investigators
decades after he
left office to figure that out and it
does happen all the time as we saw with
lbj
and fdr i spoke about that on the show a
little bit last week
in terms of what that legal strategy
looks like for trump i
did have the privilege of speaking to
rudy giuliani on friday when i was
filling in for rush
and rudy giuliani is obviously greatest
mayor in the history of new york and
he's also one of trump's lead attorneys
and he's really pursuing this election
fraud question it is a major
uphill battle so what mayor giuliani
told me is
there are hundreds of thousands of
ballots something like 600 000 ballots
in pennsylvania
that were illegally counted that's not
to say they were illegally cast
maybe they were maybe they weren't but
they were illegally counted
because there were not poll watchers
there every campaign is permitted to
have poll watchers
to make sure shenanigans don't go on
this is especially important for mail-in
ballots which are much more open to
fraud
so because those 600 000 ballots were
not counted legally
they should not be counted in the final
tally that's mayor giuliani's argument
i don't know that that's going to hold
up in court what do i know the trump
campaign has won some victories in the
pennsylvania
courts however it's very
it's difficult to throw out six ballots
much harder to throw at sixty or six
hundred to six thousand threats six
hundred thousand ballots
to me seems unlikely unless the trump
campaign
can come with hard irrefutable proof of
systemic fraud there may have been
systemic fraud and it's just impossible
to prove
we don't know but it's going to be
incumbent on the trump legal campaign to
to prove that there are other
irregularities you've heard about the
dominion
software there are allegations from
whistleblowers at dominion by the way
that dominion was very easy to misuse
there were people actually saying that
even before the election easy to hack
obviously the left has been telling us
it's easy to hack elections for years
and years now
because of they've never accepted the
results of 2016.
so obviously those questions are all all
wide open
but can you prove it can you prove it
that's the question that's going to be
up
even even if they can't there are going
to be a lot of conservatives who
are skeptical of this election and i i
know there are some people who want to
say come on we need to show
we need to only rely on the evidence we
need evidence right now
i don't think that's fair i don't think
that's fair i think the skepticism that
conservatives have
for these liberal elites is utterly
justified
i think we would be foolish not to look
at them with this skepticism
they have lied to us time and time and
time and time again
they've been wrong time and time and
time and time and time again
and i think absolutely it's they it is
the people who run the liberal
institutions
that have squandered their credibility
it's not conservatives who are
conspiracy mongering because we don't
take them
at face value if you enjoyed that video
and i
would hope that you did please be sure
to hit the subscribe button
so that all of the befuddled radicals
wading through the wasteland of youtube
knows where they can get the truth
thanks